la respuesta de polonia a la crisis
migratoria ha sido el envío del ejército
más de 12.000 soldados respaldan a la
guardia fronteriza y a la policía los
vehículos que se dirigen al oeste son
controlados por si son traficantes y
aumentan las tensiones con los
residentes locales
mariah crisis shows que tuvo
recientemente un encuentro aterrador con
un grupo de hombres armados vestidos de
civil que con algunos de ellos llevaban
máscaras con caras de calavera uno de
ellos me apuntó con una pistola y me
ordenó que saliera de mi carro a mi
amigo lo sacaron a la fuerza de su
vehículo y lo empujaron al suelo
gritaban que éramos contrabandistas y
que nos iban a juzgar aunque al
principio maría pensó que eran
vigilantes de extrema derecha resultó
que se trataba de una unidad especial de
la guardia de fronteras maría y sus
amigos no son contrabandistas pero si
intentan ayudar a los migrantes con
comida ropa y baterías hace poco ella y
su marido camille acogieron una familia
kurda durante varias noches
y
esta es arriba y danna y su marido él
estaba en el hospital cuando ella fue
brutalmente empujada a belarús sola con
sus hijos después de dos días aquí se
transformaron ya no les persiguen en el
bosque ya no están aterrorizados porque
entendieron que esto es realmente una
casa segura
spears camille consiguió que el tribunal
europeo de derechos humanos obliga a
polonia a dejar que la familia se quede
al menos un mes aunque su destino a
largo plazo es incierto nos lleva al
lugar donde los encontró
venimos a lugares como éste casi todos
los días hay mucha gente esperando en el
bosque y es demasiado fácil decir que
esto es el arma de lukashenko tenemos
que recordar que se trata de personas y
que necesitan ayuda
sin embargo incluso los esfuerzos de la
población local están limitados por la
zona de exclusión de emergencia
establecida en septiembre una franja de
unos tres kilómetros de ancho prohibida
e incluso fuera de la zona los controles
policiales son habituales